before Fran thing comes law becomes this
massive one of the biggest hits of all
time in a Brock history you befriend
George Harrison mmm-hmm now a guy with
your kind of guitar chops and experience
and singing and everything
are you nervous when George calls you up
and says I'm leaving The Beatles and I
know I think I need you yeah like how
does that work the first time that I met
him a friend and assistant Terry Doran
he we were in Wardour Street in London
and that's the studio is just around the
corner trident and we were in the pub
and he said you want to come with me
George and I said George oh yeah those
guys all called him suck like they think
you know who they are I think when we
joy in George yeah he had some he had
some codename for him as well right so
so they could talk about him in public
you know yeah I heard like guys that
famous get code name what was George
Harrison's code name it was Harry I
think big Harrison you know I think was
a Harry something like that right but do
you want to come meet Harry you know so
so I walk in the studio and there's
George standing behind the console and
he looked at me and he goes hello Pete
you know and I kind of look behind
myself isn't is there another Pete here
how did he know you so well was he from
humble pie humble pie and he requested
you because he had to put up together
musicians for this thing even he we
didn't know we were gonna meet that day
and he just said look I'm producing my
first album for the Apple label The
Beatles Apple so I walk down and it's
the who's who of players who's in there
ringo and klaus voormann Nicky Hopkins
Oh Mike all these like top top guys and
Chris Spedding probably is dead that's
exciting right uh yes I was nervous as
hell and then George just hands me his
Les Paul the famous one not that he's
not famous but that's his guitar but
it's it's very there's a storied past so
and I saw as you have no idea you were
going there to play you were just gonna
meet George you Harry yeah give you a
code name was my coach
hey kid get over here just peter
frampton so so then I start playing
rhythm because he is the Beatles lead
guitar player
so he says no no I'm playing rhythm I
want you to play lead you know so I
swallowed hard and I ended up playing
the main guitar riffs on this first
single as a musician who puts together
his own music are you shocked that when
you walked into that room he wanted you
to play lead because you're probably
because like you say he needles lead
guitar play why do you think he needed
you to play lead was just he was just
looking for something different a
different sound um I know that he was
you know he was a fan of my playing ROM
and he just you know that Daddy what
you'll do with absolutely yeah and and
you're sitting there and all those guys
from jamming with you and I sort of
became he said well look if Eric can't
make it all cold Pete you know which was
very nice but I you know I know
everything Eric Clapton yes I know where
I stand your secondary it's not a bad
place for me oh absolutely you take that
as an insult no no way